Esta es una imagen del famoso parque de
béisbol Green Monster en Boston lo que
queremos hacer es calcular Como una
pelota de béisbol puede superar esta
Barrera
o lo que es lo mismo con qué fuerza o
qué velocidad debo de golpear esta
pelota de béisbol para que pueda superar
esta Barrera y salga del estadio para
que haga algo más o menos así
la pelota
bueno la distancia de aquí de Home hasta
la Barrera es de unos 96 metros y la
altura de esta Barrera es de 11.3 metros
Así que ahora vamos a
dibujar estos vectores para analizarlos
bueno vemos que la pelota va a ser
golpeada no a nivel del suelo sino más o
menos un metro por encima de home o de
este plato Entonces vamos a dibujar aquí
nuestra pelota
de béisbol y va a estar a una distancia
aproximada de
un metro por encima
del suelo Este es el suelo
y va a ser golpeada no sabemos todavía
con Qué velocidad justamente es lo que
queremos saber
Pero bueno este es el vector velocidad
inicial que queremos encontrar y va a
ser golpeada
esta pelota
con un ángulo
de 45 grados y bueno vamos a aplicar lo
que acabamos de aprender en el vídeo
anterior sobre notación vectorial para
que no sean más fáciles los cálculos
vamos a descomponer este vector
en sus elementos horizontales y
verticales entonces tengo aquí si yo
quiero dibujar
su componente
horizontal
este componente Quiero conocer su
magnitud y ya hemos visto en videos
anteriores que para la magnitud en este
caso de la componente horizontal
velocidad inicial va a ser
nuestro componente horizontal x va a ser
igual a la magnitud de este vector que
todavía no conozco pero es la velocidad
inicial por el coseno
del ángulo que en este caso son 45
grados Quiero saber o conocer la
magnitud de mi componente
vertical
en este caso mi componente vertical
sería igual al valor de la hipotenusa o
la magnitud de la velocidad inicial por
el seno del ángulo de 45 grados
de nuestras ecuaciones identidades
trigonométricas sabemos que este coseno
de 45 grados va a ser igual a raíz de 2
entre 2 y este seno de 45 grados
va a ser igual a también
raíz de 2 entre 2 y ahora podemos
expresar nuestro vector inicial con la
anotación
vectorial
el vector inicial es igual a la suma de
sus componentes tenemos primero el
componente horizontal que es igual a
mi velocidad o bueno vamos a escribirlo
primero así a raíz de 2 entre 2
multiplicado por mi velocidad inicial
por la unidad vectorial y
más la componente vertical que es
también raíz de 2 entre 2 por la
velocidad inicial
por la unidad vectorial j y aquí sí
tenemos expresado en notación vectorial
nuestra vector inicial que queremos
conocer cuáles son sus valores ahora por
otra parte vamos a analizar el
desplazamiento que va a realizar la
pelota tenemos que esta pelota
va a tener que desplazarse
una distancia
de 96 metros que es la distancia
de Home hasta la primera barrera o hasta
la Barrera del parque 96 metros y la
Barrera del parque
mide no tiene una altura
nuestra escala
y no está derecha veamos
esta Barrera Obviamente si estuviera
escala tendréis que estar mucho más alta
mide
11.3 metros
pero tomen en cuenta que el
desplazamiento vertical de mi pelota no
va a ser de 11.3 metros porque tenemos
que la pelota no fue golpeada desde
el suelo al nivel del suelo sino tiene
un metro
de bueno va a ser golpeada un metro por
encima del nivel del suelo entonces la
el vector desplazamiento vertical de mi
pelota va a ser igual a
10.3 metros
Bueno vamos a analizar nuestro
desplazamiento nuestro vector
desplazamiento
y encontramos una velocidad inicial lo
suficientemente grande para apenas
superar esta Barrera entonces todas las
velocidades mayores a esta Pues también
lo van a hacer así que vamos a definir
algo que llamamos desplazamiento
necesario el desplazamiento requerido
para que la pelota salga del parque lo
mínimo indispensable Entonces el
desplazamiento necesario lo voy a poner
en otro color
es ese subíndice n porque es la n es de
necesario ese desplazamiento o este
vector desplazamiento
va a tener una componente connotación
vectorial
de 96
no voy a escribir las unidades para
ahorrar espacio 96
en multiplicado por la unidad vectorial
y
más
10.3
la unidad vectorial J esto es la mínima
de desplazamiento que tenemos que tener
o superar para que nuestra pelota salga
del parque si encontramos
digamos que definimos nuestra
desplazamiento con base o en función al
tiempo entonces podremos
calcular la velocidad necesaria para
obtener ese desplazamiento necesario Así
que ahora vamos a escribir nuestra
fórmula del desplazamiento cómo funciona
del tiempo
Entonces es desplazamiento
como función del tiempo estate significa
el tiempo desde que se golpeó la pelota
el tiempo transcurrido desde que la
pelota fue golpeada Y esto es igual
a la velocidad inicial
multiplicada por este tiempo
de hecho esta la voy a poner en Amarillo
para distinguirla
y esto se suma
a la mitad
de la aceleración
del vector aceleración de hecho todos
estos son vectores por el tiempo
transcurrido
al cuadrado
esa fórmula ya la hemos visto antes pero
usaba en lugar de la t usaba una Delta t
pero ahora no la voy a escribir para
ahorrar el tiempo Bueno más que el
tiempo el espacio
tenemos que esta fórmula pues no
conocemos la velocidad inicial y tampoco
conocemos el tiempo ahora queremos
usarla de manera que nos queden dos
ecuaciones y dos incógnitas pues para
poder encontrar la solución
También tenemos nuestros vectores
expresados en notación vectorial por lo
que los cálculos van a ser mucho más
fáciles lo único que nos falta de esta
fórmula por conocer es el vector
aceleración
el vector aceleración
pues es el que ocurre debido a la acción
de la gravedad
de la tierra cercana sobre un objeto
cercano a la superficie de la Tierra
esta aceleración este no tiene
componente horizontal por lo que va a
ser igual
a cero
y
no es decir no tiene componente
horizontal
menos porque va hacia abajo la dirección
de la aceleraciones hacia abajo y las
direcciones negativas pues indican
justamente bueno las cantidades
negativas indican que va hacia abajo se
invierte el vector j
queda en dirección opuesta por lo que
aquí me queda que es igual a menos
9.8
J igual es 9.8 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado pero no estoy poniendo las
unidades para ahorrar espacio ahora sí
ya tenemos lo necesario para hacer los
cálculos Sólo nos falta establecer dos
restricciones y podremos encontrar la
magnitud de la velocidad inicial esto lo
terminaremos en el siguiente video